السلام عليكم معكم سفيان ثابت ونستعرض معا
ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بانجازا وفي
نشره الهند تحضر برنامج استقصائيا للجزيره
يتحدث عن معاناه المسلمين
يقول ان الذكاء الاصطناعي تهديد وجودي
للبشريه واكبر كارثه في البحر المتوسط
واخبار اخرى لنتابعها
سلام حدثينا اكثر عن سبب وحيثيات هذا
القرار
قرار حظر فيلم الهند من اجل الفتيل ضمن
تحقيقات برنامج المسافه صفر هو جاءك خطوه
استباقيه قبل بث الفيلم باللغه الانجليزيه
وهذه هي المره الاولى التي يتم اتخاذ فيها
قرار بحظر فيلم من خلال اعلى سلطه قضائيه
وهي المحكمه العليا في ولايه اوتار براديش
في السابق كانت هذه القرارات تتخذ من قبل
الحكومه في بيان المحكمه يقولون بان
الفيلم يدعو الى الكراهيه وفي ذات البيان
يقولون ايضا بان الفيلم سوف يحال الى جهات
المختصه من اجل فحص المحتوى هذا يعني بان
قرار الحظر جاء قبل فحص المحتوى طبعا كل
ذلك يحدث في دوله تقدم نفسها على انها
اكبر ديمقراطيه في العالم
شكرا سلام وفي كارثه جديده وصفت بالاكبر
والاسوا في البحر المتوسط غرق مركب يقل
مئات المهاجرين قباله السواحل اليونان
شهود عيان قالوا ان عددهم يقدر بنحو 700
شخص كانوا متكدسين في قارب صيد متهالك خفر
السواحل اليوناني اعلنتشال عشرات الجثث
وانقاذ اكثر من 100 شخص بينما اعتبر 500
في عداد المفقودين رواد منصات تفاعلوا
بشده على وقع هذه الماساه لنقرا بعض
التغريدات
ساره تقول ترك الاشخاص يموتون غرقا ليس
حادثا بل جريمه قتل عمد ابنائنا ليسوا
ارقاما بينما قال ياسر الزعاتره البحر
يواصل اخذ حصته من ارواح الفقراء غرب
استعمر وقتل ونهب العالم الثالث ثم دعم
انظمه فاسده ثم فرض عولم على مقاسه والان
يتنصل من مسؤوليته الى السودان حيث
يتصاعدت حده الاشتباكات في مناطق متفرقه
من العاصمه الخرطوم طوال الاسبوع الماضي
وقد دخلت المعارك شهرها الثالث في حين قتل
والي غرب دارفور عبد الله ابو بكر بعد
اعتقاله من قبل قوات الدعم السريع وهو
ارفع مسؤول يقتل منذ بدء الصراع في هذا
البرنامج
استشهد الشاب الفلسطيني خليل يحيى الانيس
برصاص قوات الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها مدينه
نابلس بينما اصيب الشابان اخرون بالرصاص
الحي في الراس والفخذ من جانب اخر فجرت
قوته الاحتلال منزل الاسير اسامه الطويل
في مدينه نابلس بعد ان حاصرتها كما تجددت
المواجهات بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال عاقبه تفجير المنزل ينضم الينا
الان المحامي في هيئه شؤون الاسرى خالد
محاشنه
سيد خالد اهلا بك اذا لماذا يقوم الاحتلال
بتفجيري منزل اسير فلسطيني هدم بيوت اسرار
فلسطينيين واجراء قمعي وغير قانوني عنصري
تقوم به اسرائيل منذ سنوات طويله ولكن
بالفتره الاخيره ازدادت وتيره استعماله
بحق الاصل الفلسطينيين وعائلاتهم الهدف من
هذا الاجراء القمعي هو عمليا محاوله
وبوهيه ردع الاخرين من القيام باعمال
مشابهه قاموا بها الاسرى الفلسطينيين
والهدف الاخر وعمليا الانتقام من الاسرى
وعائلاتهم ومحاوله تخويف المجتمع الحاضن
لهؤلاء الاسرى والتسبب بالذات العائلات
باضرار ماديه معنويه ونفسيه من كل هذا
الاجراء
شكرا لك سيد خالد الاسبوع الماضي شهد
زياره رسميه لامير دوله قطر الى العراق هي
الاولى لزعيم عربي منذ تشكيل الحكومه
الجديده الزياره تخللها توقيع عدد من
الاتفاقيات ومذكرات التفاهم كما اعرب
الشيخ تميما حمد الثاني عن عزم قطر
استثمار خمسه مليارات دولار في عدد من
القطاعات في العراق خلال السنوات المقبله
الذكاء الاصطناعي التهديد وجودي للبشريه
لا يقل عن الحرب النوويه هذا ما قاله
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش خلال مؤتمر صحفي طلب فيه بعمل
عالمي واضح ومنسق وباخذ تلك التحذيرات
بجديه بالغه في سياق ذاته اقر الاتحاد
الاوروبي تعديلات على مسوده لقواعد الذكاء
الاصطناعي لتشمل حظرا على استخدامه في رصد
القياسات الحيويه هذه التحضيرات تدفعنا
لتساؤل عن مدى خطوره الذكاء الاصطناعي
وكنا سالناكم ان كان بالفعل يشكل خطرا
وجوديا على البشر وقد اجبتم بنسبه 59 في
المئه بانه او الذكاء الاصطناعي فعلا يمثل
خطرا على البشريه فيما 41% فقط راوا بانه
لا يؤثر ولا يمثل اي خطر
[تصفيق]
كان هذا الاسبوع حافلا ايضا في المجال
الرياضي نتعرف على اخر الاخبار لهذا
الاسبوع مع عمار نامق عمار ارحب بك ما اخر
الاخبار في البدايه مساك الله بالخير
سفيان هذا الاسبوع اسبوع الماضي كان حافل
رياضيا لماذا لسبب جدا مهم هو انه مانشستر
سيتي يتوج للمره الاولى في تاريخه بلقب
دوري ابطال اوروبا وكان سفيان مدينه
اسطنبول اصبحت فالخير على الانديه
الانجليزيه
الجميع يتذكر انه في 2005 ليفربول تمكن من
اتجاه اللقب عزيز جدا من ميلان الايطالي
وهذه المره ايضا مانشستر تمكن من انتزاع
اللقب من القطب الثاني في مدينه ميلان
انتر انتر ميلان الايطالي وتمكن من احراز
اول لقب عزيزي في تاريخه الاحداث في
الاسبوع الماضي لم تنتهي عند هذا الحد بل
ان هناك بطوله كاس افريقيا دوري ابطال
افريقيا هناك كانه قصه عشق غريبه بين
النادي الاهلي ودوري ابطال افريقيا وتمكن
النادي الاهلي ايضا من انتزاع لقب غالي
وعزيز افريقيًا على القاره الافريقيه طبعا
على حساب الوداد البيضاوي المغربي شكرا
جزيلا لك عمار نامق بهذا اذا نصل الى
نهايه الاجازه الاسبوعي الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]